I think some nice guys know that someone
who can be absolutely you said you said
the onus isn't on it's not I don't think
the owners of um guys who don't have
confidence to speak to women's on women
that is your personality trait and
that's got nothing to do with me you
don't think I think it can be because I
think this comes so I think these
conversation is that we tend to
generalize a lot and I get it because I
guess that's what is in your in your
view so it's easy to generalize but I
think there are nice guys who because
reading truly it's not like this there's
a lot of nice guys that are single yeah
they're getting girls yeah and some of
them yeah so I think it's just I think
it's easy for us to obviously say that
you know we can talk about certain type
of girls and blah blah because that's
really what's in our view but I don't
believe if I meet a guy who's shy and
whatever I don't believe that women have
women I think he's he's um personality
anyway he's an introvert or he's shy
anyway and maybe that is heightened when
you meet other women and you can't
doesn't have the confidence but I don't
think that Oneness is on women in making
him shy
it's not the onuses on women it's like
we're responsible for the men that we
pick yeah yeah I agree with that part
but she was saying how um she thinks
that guys are like the shy guys they
don't have the Communist approachment
because
partially but it's partially our fault
because feminism had this whole me too
move here yeah so and so like we're
complaining like they're shy because
they don't know if they're going to be
me too if they approach the wrong girl
no no seriously there's there's
there is a YouTuber that just came out
where he he approached a girl in public
and she literally called the the Park
police on him and this was in 2022.
there was guys that was shy before the
meeting was started
wait how old are you I'm 27. like so me
too was what five seven years ago yeah
how long were you really in the dating
game yeah that's the thing because I've
got no life experience okay actually I'm
gonna ask Auntie dude Auntie do you feel
like men approach women more or less now
can they approach women less now because
women look more Fierce they were more
war paint
and because the men are scared
because nowadays it takes a couple of
rare things to happen for all men to be
labeled so now you don't even know
whether to approach a woman or not
because you don't know whether she's
going to say that you're harassing her
leave her alone and sometimes you might
hear this one a woman might just a man
might just want to say excuse me love do
you know that no
take your watch a girl drops something
and I've gone to give it back and she
gave me some dirty look I was like so I
took it I snapped it was Oyster card I
snapped and went and went my way yeah
okay and that's that's why a lot of men
just don't approach women like your
personality trait you can be quite shy
and introvert me personally I'm very
very shy but when you are in a situation
where you feel comfortable you can come
out of your shell and with some guys you
know with some girls they can come out
their shell whereas other women have
made them feel no you stay shy because
women
I don't think that I think guys will
approach you if they feel good about
themselves so if they feel like they're
you know put pushing gym or whatever
that to build their own self-confidence
I I know you guys that feel good about
themselves like they're like yeah I'm
good looking I go to the gym you know
I'm a nice person and he won't approach
a girl but he'll look at a girl and be
like no I won't approach her because we
we like or that girl looks so good and
no no no no no
this is the death of femininity I think
a lot more women are masculine because
back in the day women would signal and
even when we had kit on the other day he
he educates women yeah he educates women
how to signal to allow a man to to feel
comfortable enough to get um to approach
again
maybe the problem is men aren't actually
looking for women's signal before
they're approaching so when a girl is
now calling Paw Patrol is because she's
not signaled to you she's not showed you
she's any interest in you don't know
what her relationship status is and
maybe wait for the cues for a woman
to say this I think women embody
masculinity more now no no but look at
this checklist go on I don't know if
anyone else uses tfl regularly maybe I'm
poor but you know go on the tube you see
the advert I I'm staring harassment yeah
it puts men on edge yeah
you don't want to approach a girlfriend
no but if we flip it to like countries
where there isn't that a lot of men take
advantage so it's not it these aren't
put in there for women dude the majority
of men are the majority of men the men
you're describing
sorry the majority of men Dominion
describing so the men you're saying that
take advantage is that the country like
where this isn't the social norms where
you have to but is that the majority of
men
sorry is that do you so the majority of
yeah gone do you think the majority of
men are doing that in those countries in
those countries what going up to women
unsolicited yeah 100
and they're grabbing girls in there the
majority the majority of men in those
countries are grabbing girls 100 so the
majority of men in those countries are
committing assault yes that's your view
on man no no that's not my view on men
that's cultural differences in my
country even where women's rights are
not like well I'm not I'm not here
saying women are equal to me I'm saying
but if a woman doesn't want to be
touched don't touch her that's even a
religious side if you don't touch it I'm
with you yeah so in them countries where
work countries like even parts of Asia
Africa can you name them
I've had men approach me millions and
I've said no no no approaching
you said you said wait wait you said you
said grabbed they were they were okay
even in Dubai they grabbed one of my
friends I've been to Dubai I was fine I
had no issues yeah exactly what I'm
saying again
and I went with my family family sorry
yeah
but also and again maybe this is where
the cultural differences are when it
comes to even like me traveling as an
Asian woman they don't see me as my
British passport they see me as an Asian
woman if I go to Dubai they see me as a
Bangladeshi woman and they will take
advantage of that thinking I'm a
Bangladeshi woman it's just interesting
um because I know a couple people from
those countries and they don't actually
have the same views as you
grew up in the like like um you said
well I think you said Morocco
I'll say this
the context on which in which this
happened you were on holiday right and
you're saying that people grabbed you
what was the context of that group no
I'm not saying that they're constantly
grabbing this approach the constantly
trying to talk yeah but are you but can
I say as a Moroccan were you a tourist
were you in a tourist area were you in
the Medina were they approaching you to
sell you things what no I was just
walking the beach I was walking the
beach even if it's a touristic area what
I'm saying is some countries like even
just say when I go Bangladesh and I'm
not a tourist yeah and I'm in my own
country clothes everything guys will
still feel like they can they have a
right to come and speak to you all okay
okay
yeah yeah I'm not saying it's wrong I'm
saying again look at social cues if like
you said the guys teaching girls what
signaling is if she's not making eye
contact if she's not don't maybe don't
approach her especially and that's how
they make guys for you
but do you see how this is kind of like
the situation that I was describing
because you're kind of like like me
tooing these guys because they approach
okay can I just say as a victim who has
been sexually abused as a child it's
yeah it is deep it is deep and I don't
want if I don't want you accessing my
personal space don't do it just don't
talk it's not just me talk to you no I
talk to everyone I'm a very social being
Eddie knows I'm very social you trying
to cross that line no like if I've not
necessarily the guy's fault because if
he I personally myself I've been through
the same thing but I would never be able
to look at a guy and say you know it's
your fault if I'm getting mad that
you're coming up and to talk to me I'm
not saying I get mad he doesn't he
doesn't know what's happened to you so
he shouldn't be able to feel like too
shy to still come true I will never call
a man or call police on a man trying to
say hello to me at the park I will smile
and I'll go on my way if he is now
following me and trying to take
advantage of that situation yes I will
panic and that's again my traumas I'll
Panic if he understands oh she doesn't
want to say hello and he might his
business there's no problem that's what
it is but you said the majority of men
are grabbing girls
and that's and that's where like I have
an issue with that because I don't think
you're correct I know people from those
countries and they would not say the
same thing so it's interesting to me
that's your view because it to me that's
like that's like your view on men
I'm not saying that it doesn't happen
I'm not saying it doesn't happen we're
saying it's not the majority okay it
happens it happens it's time to go out
and it might be my figure it might be my
and that's why again I don't like to
when I go especially abroad I don't wear
clothes that will extenuate my figure as
much or my skin because I like to
protect myself yeah it might be that
they find me attractive and they want to
maybe every girl doesn't experience that
but every time I go out I do get
approached or I do get spoken to and I
have to now I smile it's not like I'm
calling police but I'll be like no sorry
I'm not interested or okay yeah no you
know I'm not single and I get I guess
every girl says that to you guys I'm not
single then they'll be like oh what so
yeah you can't have a side boyfriend
what happens
I don't but I don't think like if a
guy's persistent like I'm not I don't
think that's that bad like no one's
saying it's bad it's like I don't I
don't think he should grab you I think
that's like okay don't don't but like
you're telling me you you went to this
country and every single guy you saw are
like let's say so the majority so it's a
six out of ten guys you saw grabbed you
no not grab they will approach me okay
but approaching is an assault no it's
not that it's an assault but it could
lead if I keep smiling and entertaining
it and not saying putting my boundary on
he might think oh she's interested and
it's very hard for when times I feel
like we say yes just because it's easier
like I take guy's number just because
that's not their fault like to me like
if a guy approaches me again again like
it's annoying but who cares like I I've
been in like I've been I went to
Martinique I don't know if you've heard
of it yeah
it's not it's nice and like guys they're
they're like at this beach would like
come up to me and I'm like who cares I'd
be like go away okay but maybe um sorry
babes I think it can be intimidating I
think the way a person can approach you
like I think some people I think it
depends on each Essence like how you are
I guess but I think sometimes the way
even the way a guy will approach you can
make you uncomfortable I'm a confident
person
and I've had guys approach me that's
made me feel intimidated I've given guys
my number just so that this interaction
can end I've had some I went to a party
one time and the guy was like I think it
was a security at the venue and I left
and I didn't realize he was following me
and I'm walking down a dark Road I get
in my car thankfully as soon as I get in
the car I lock the doors I lock the door
he's like he's like oh that trying to
get my attention I was like oh I'm not
interested because this is I feel unsafe
in this situation he stood there he
stood there getting his phone not like
he's talking to me I'm looking at him
like bro and I was annoying because I
was in the tight space I couldn't just
kind of just drive off so I think some
guys it can be like it's just
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible